oui samedi prochain dans la deuxième
partie de cette émission bien vous
pourrez voir des extraits des comédies
musicales qui ont marqué le cinéma
américain dans les années 1930 1940 avec
bien sûr fred astaire et ginger rogers
cinéma aussi ce soir sur tf1 à 20h30
avec les animaux sont dans la ville
c'est un film de peter hunt l'histoire
d'une petite ville tout à fait
tranquille qui tout d'un coup voit sa
vie bouleversée par l'arrivée d'animaux
sauvages échappés d'une réserve
il en résulte bien sûr des scènes de
terreur faso au tigré aux ours mais
aussi des scènes comiques est plutôt
inattendue entre autres pour rattraper
les autruches donc ce soir à 20h30 ce
film puis je vous rappelle aussi qu
après cette projection nous repartirons
en compagnie de l'équipe du commandant
cousteau à la recherche des trésors
perdus et des civilisations perdues
puisque ce soir nous repartirons à la
recherche de l'atlantide
voilà donc pour notre soirée dans
quelques instants le journal tf1
actualité et aujourd'hui nous allons
retrouver yves mourousi assure end où il
va nous présenter le journal chez une
famille de téléspectateurs